hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome my
channel with today I wanted to talk
about something that I feel like is a
huge deal that I have not seen that many
people talking about I probably wouldn't
have even made this video if I felt like
this story got a little bit more
attention but it is very interesting to
me at the very least and that is as this
headline on techradar.com says that
deaths stranding based on what we can
see may no longer be a PlayStation 4
exclusive game obviously it's one of the
last few ps4 exclusives this generation
with Costa Tsushima and lost of uh spot
two and just for those who didn't know
Kojima Productions isn't a Sony fusspot
II studio they are an independent studio
it's just that on December 16 2015 they
made a joint announcement with Sony
Computer Entertainment that it would be
reestablished as an independent studio
and that it would develop a new
franchise to PlayStation 4 which we now
know is des training but they can make
games for xbox or for PC at any point in
time but to jump to how this story kind
of got out earlier this week basically
if you go on the PlayStation site the
section that lists all the games that a
PlayStation exclusive included death
stranding which you can see if you use
wayback machine but if you go now and
you look at it today which I will do for
all of you under D deaths training is
gone
so it was that at some point there's a
screenshot of it right below dead nation
it's no longer that which is just clone
number one but obviously that was a
decision made to do that and that was on
the Australian site but all the other
official PlayStation sites did the same
thing if we take a look at Germany for
example we scroll down I assume these
are the same they updated by the same
people they just get localised remotely
again it's not that so then another
tidbit this is an archive press release
from Sony themselves which was
announcing their agreement with Koji Pro
and that does say that the agreement was
just to develop its first software title
as a console exclusive to the ps4
console exclusive again they notify
spotty studio not every Kojima
Productions game is going to be only on
PlayStation see right there does this
mean Kojima Productions now
Long's under SCE WWS no it is an
independent studio so if we jump down
here I think that most people probably
did not know the question is what other
platforms will Kojima's first
independent title be available on
besides ps4 it says the title is planned
to become available on PC off to ps4 and
then how long is the exclusivity we are
not disclosing details so I guess we
just don't have the answer to that yet
so that does mean that even back then it
was announced for PC we've just never
heard about the PC details and I think
everyone forgot and is heralding death
stranding as being a ps4 exclusive even
though it's not so another thing that
people have pointed out is that the
cover OTT doesn't have the only on
PlayStation banner which most
PlayStation exclusives have so I feel
like it's not really that people were
tricked per se it's just that if you
don't look into any of these details you
wouldn't really know this unless you saw
that first press release because I
couldn't find any reference of it
outside of that particular thing
happening and the same he's a vest an on
reddit has a theory which is that kojima
probably wants to put it on pc in
general and maybe that's in pot by being
impressed with the tech of the the
decima engine that he got from
gorilla-like that's entirely possible
and there are people in this started
wondering if maybe it'll be announced at
Gamescom or something like that so
related to that a guy who guessed death
strandings released it perfectly also
said that it would be a PlayStation
exclusive only for a period of time
before hitting PC and he'd guessed that
it would be six months or a year of
exclusivity on PlayStation 4 and one
thing that a lot of people on reset are
talking about which i think is funny is
what the fight for death stranding is
going to be is it just going to come to
every platform on PC or is this gonna be
like an epic game still fight is this
why we start seeing the fight go beyond
console exclusives and then into also
being on PC but being PC exclusive to a
platform which is obviously already a
thing for a few games but I just feel
like it happening in the other auto
where it seemed like it was a ps4
exclusive and then becomes exclusive to
a specific PC platform just seems wild
but as this guy pointed out Briah
if epic is the one who pays to get it to
come to his PC they're not necessarily
the bad guys
it's kind of cool for everyone means we
get 60 frames a second it does look like
a really pretty game could end up being
a stadia exclusive we ultimately don't
know but uh yeah this is obviously just
a very chill quick video I just wanted
to kind of spread the awareness on it
because I feel like most people don't
know that it seems like destiny is also
coming to PC hopefully we get an
announcement about that on a date
sometime soon and I guess technically
because that press release that
information was out there it just hasn't
resurfaced for a long time until it was
removed from this here list and we found
out that it was no longer you know here
cookies no longer actually on the ps4
exclusives list which is still a very
pretty list it's still good and
obviously ps4 still got goes to Tsushima
and lots of it spot to which I'm sure
will be absolutely incredible so I don't
feel like it's a loss for the
PlayStation community or anything I
don't feel like exclusives are anyway
more people getting to play the thing
always seems good to me
I would never complain about more people
having access to something it's great
but I just wanted to talk about it so
that's it from me today everyone I will
see you guys next time